happy almost friday today we're talking
about how god of war got delayed how the
gta remaster is getting a little bit
realer by the day
and what you can expect from sony's new
first party studio blue point my name is
devonte chisholm and you're watching
gamespot news
first off let's talk about who's to
blame for the god of war delay
kratos
[Music]
well not quite it's actually christopher
judge the voice of kratos on twitter
judd said in part ragnarok was delayed
because of me august 2019 i couldn't
walk had to have back surgery both hips
replaced and knee surgery they waited
for me to rehab now i don't know about
you but that's a good enough reason to
me and i'm really glad that christopher
is feeling better however
sony santa monica you could have hit me
up all right i could have stepped in
boy
nailed it
moving on to a story that wasn't in the
intro the game awards are officially
back the show's creator and host jeff
keeley took to twitter to announce the
ceremony will take place live in person
at the microsoft theater in la on
thursday december 9th unfortunately
there was no showtime given for the
announcement but i'd assume that it's
going to air around 6 pm et 3 pm pt but
we'll let you know when the times become
official comment down below what game
you're hoping to see at this year's show
and you can't say elden ring you can't
say skate 4 and please for the love of
all things gaming don't say gta 5.
but speaking of the grand theft auto
series the rumored gta remastered
collection just got a little bit realer
recently korea's ratings board published
the rating for grand theft auto the
trilogy the definitive edition and while
the game still hasn't been officially
announced these ratings do suggest that
the game is real the rumored remaster
collection is said to include grand
theft auto 3 grand theft auto san
andreas and grand theft auto vice city
and was reportedly planned to launch
sooner but the covet 19 pandemic
affected those plans the games will
apparently run on the unreal engine and
the idea is for them to stay mostly true
to their ps2 era origins but with better
resolution and a new ui announcement at
the game awards i mean come on that'd be
pretty hype i can't lie
but okay to the most unsurprising news
of the day sony has acquired bluepoint
if you didn't know bluepoint is the
studio that developed the ps4 remake of
shadow of the colossus and most recently
developed the demon souls remake for
playstation 5. however don't expect them
to stay in the remake boat as it seems
their new project will be an original
one while speaking to ign blue point
president marco thrush said original
content is the next step in the studio's
evolution but he didn't say what the
project would be
but alright comment down below what you
want to see at the game awards remember
those rules and go check out some of our
new world content i've been working
pretty hard on it between live streams
and tip videos so if you're into the
game or just even a little bit curious
jump in check it out especially if
you're waiting online in a queue
[Applause]
[Music]
you